so we've been talking about the system
of jim crow segregation and in the last
video we left off
in 1876
and in 1876 there was a contested
presidential election between a
republican candidate
named
rutherford b hayes
and a democratic candidate
named samuel j tilden
and in this election there was one of
the rare cases
where tilden actually won
the popular vote whereas hayes
won the electoral vote so there's a
standoff in congress for months over how
this presidential election is going to
end and eventually they make kind of a
backroom deal known as the compromise of
1877.
and
in this compromise
the democrats and the republicans agree
that hayes
a republican will get to be president of
the united states in exchange
the military forces that have been
occupying the south especially the last
two states of louisiana and south
carolina and have been enforcing the
14th amendment or the equal citizenship
of african americans in the south
they're going to leave they're going to
go back to their barracks and will no
longer interfere in the political system
of the south so with the compromise of
1877 the republican party which has been
standing behind the rights of african
americans remember the republicans for
the party of abraham lincoln pretty much
gives up as a party on trying to ensure
the racial equality of african americans
now why did they do this i think mainly
this was a question of weariness and
giving up on their part remember that
the civil war ended in
1865. now it's 12 years later in 1877
and there are still federal troops in
the south so imagine if you were a
parent in massachusetts and you thought
that your son who was enlisted in the
union army was going to come home in
1865 and now it's 1877 and he's still in
south carolina seems like a long time to
fight a war so that's one part of it the
other part of it is that in 1873
there is an economic panic this is an
early depression
you know we often think of the great
depression as the only time the united
states was stricken with an economic
downturn but before the depression there
were about 20-year cycles of boom and
bust so in 1873 there was an economic
bust that meant that people had less
money to throw at the problem of
reconstruction in the south and i would
say the last part of this is a
combination of racism
and
the new labor movement in the north
so as whites in the north got farther
and farther away from the civil war the
animating spirit of abolition started to
fade among many northerners the late
19th century was an era of increasing
racialization especially as new ethnic
classes came into the united states from
southern and eastern europe and so there
was a new interpretation of race that
really came to the foreground in this
time period which we call social
darwinism and we'll talk more about that
in other videos but the interpretation
of racial difference and hierarchy among
the races became more broadly accepted
throughout the united states not just in
the south so in 1877
the federal troops in the south that are
remaining pack their bags and go home
meaning that african americans in the
south have no one to protect them from
the southern governments and so within
months many of these governments passed
the laws which we now call jim crow laws
and these are the laws which prevent
african americans from voting prevent
intermarriage between whites and blacks
and also enact all of these separations
of public accommodations that we now
associate with jim crow sitting in the
back of the bus using a separate water
fountain now if it sounds like these
sorts of laws are directly in
contradiction with the 14th amendment
which says that
laws
cannot
target a specific race that there is
equal protection under the law for
everyone born in the united states
you're right that's exactly what these
laws are they are a contradiction of the
14th amendment and in 1896
a man named homer plessy
was arrested for sitting in a white
train compartment he thought rosa parks
was the first but in fact it's homer
plessy who tries to desegregate trains
in fact he's trying to test the
constitutionality of having segregated
train compartments in 1896 and his case
goes all the way to the supreme court
which rules that it is fine to separate
the races as long as separate
accommodations are equal
so this is the place where separate but
equal comes in
now
in theory
separate accommodations for whites and
blacks were supposed to be equal in
reality they almost never were and in
fact it was the very separation itself
that implied the inequality and that is
what the naacp is going to argue in the
brown versus board of education case in
1954 which overturns this doctrine of
separate but equal but in between this
period of 1877
and
1954
jim crow laws were on the books in all
of the southern states but i don't want
you to come away thinking that things
were terrible in the south and that the
north was a racial utopia even though
segregation laws and violence such as
lynching to enforce segregation laws
existed mainly in the south de facto
segregation and widespread racial
prejudice also existed in the north
particularly in housing and job
discrimination and of course 1954 the
brown versus board of education decision
didn't end segregation or end racial
prejudice in the united states it's
enforcing the end of segregation and
enforcing the end of some of these de
facto forms of segregation and racial
prejudice in the north that will be the
real focus of the civil rights movement
so i think the real tragedy of the jim
crow era was that it didn't have to be
this way in fact it was just in this
presidential election of 1876 that the
federal government more or less gave up
on protecting the rights of african
americans it's interesting to imagine
what life in the south might have been
like had the federal government not
given up perhaps it would be very
different perhaps it would not but it's
hard not to mourn the lost opportunity
of reconstruction this 12-year period
where african americans had voting
rights and often served in public office
instead the united states doomed
african-american citizens in the south
to another almost 100 years of
second-class status in our society